I'll have a shot of whiskey, a gin & tonic,
and a home pregnancy test - to go, please.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and you know
who has it the worst?
Pregnant women.
They can't have caffeine, they can't smoke,
and they definitely can't drink alcohol - though
that doesn't always stop everyone.
According to the CDC, 1 in 13 women admit
to drinking while pregnant, and 1 in 70 women
admit to binge drinking.
Some states, including Alaska, which has the
highest rate of fetal alcohol syndrome in
the country - have even resorted to administering
free pregnancy tests at bars, in order to
raise awareness about the disease.
But what is fetal alcohol syndrome?
And is it a guaranteed thing if you drink
while pregnant?
Well, not really.
We've known since the late 60s that alcohol
can cause birth defects.
When a pregnant woman drinks, the alcohol
passes through the placenta to the fetus,
and gets into your baby's bloodstream.
The problem is that babies metabolize alcohol
way slower than adults do - so 1 drink to
you is like 4 drinks to them.
Now 4 drinks probably won't harm you - but
in fetuses, it interferes with the delivery
of oxygen and nutrition they need in order
to keep growing.
That's why exposure to alcohol - especially
in excessive amounts - can disrupts your baby's
development, causing growth problems and brain
damage.
Physically, it has very characteristic effects.
Children with FAS typically have microcephaly,
which is a smaller than normal head; as well
as eyes that are smaller, and more far apart,
than normal.
Now you're probably wondering, why do women
continue to drink during pregnancy, even when
they know it's bad for their baby?
There are a couple reasons.
For one, most women don't even know they're
pregnant, until they're at least a month in.
And research shows that alcohol is the most
harmful to fetuses during the first 3 months
of pregnancy.
So there's a good chance many of the women
whose children have FAS, didn't even know
they were doing them harm.
Now you could argue that if you found out
you were pregnant, and knew you'd been drinking
heavily during that time, you could always
abort.
But it's unrealistic to expect everyone to
take that option.
Another potential cause of FAS, is plain and
simple alcoholism.
It's a disease, and a devastating one that
can take over our rational brain and make
us do things that we know are bad.
But how bad is bad?
And how much alcohol would it take to cause
something like fetal alcohol syndrome?
Think of like a spectrum.
On the one end, having 1 drink per day or
less, has really not been associated with
any risk of FAS.
On the other end of the spectrum, you have
children with full-on FAS, whose mothers typically
consumed 8 - 10 drinks per day.
In the middle, women who have 4-6 drinks per
day, typically produce children with mild
FAS.
But even 1-2 drinks per day, substantially
increases the odds of stunting your child's
growth.
Which is why public health experts recommend
the "better safe than sorry" approach.
No alcohol, no worries.
What do you think?
One drink won't kill your unborn baby, but
is the 30-minute buzz you get really worth
the constant worrying?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below
- and as always, thank you guys for watching.